how excited are you right now me excited
me so excited
you also said you so emotional
yes that too tell me why um
i'm really good at uh
withholding my emotions i think that i
love comedy and i love to kind of i
would love to act one day but i think
that that has been such a passion where
i'm
i'm good at
closing those emotions closing those
the reality of how i feel in
and
so so i think tonight was one of those
nights where
it kind of came out in a way where no
one's ever
been able to kind of see it
tell me how you really feel
uh
i feel
me feel good i like to downplay
but this is a
it's a big deal
where me going tonight
me going to maybe a bar with locals and
roaches walking around
and hopefully that's the case and that's
kind of my goal
but
yeah no i'm very very happy i'm excited
i'm
i'm blessed and it means a lot to me
and it means a lot to my team and i
think that that's why it kind of hit me
so hard because
it was um something that we all
imagined in the beginning seven years
ago eight years ago really this was the
dream yeah i have never taken
such a fast
piss
in my whole life
so explain to me the bathroom you were
going to the bathroom um i i needed to i
had so much champagne there were so many
performances that were amazing and you
have to toast and you're like you go you
and you're performing whatever anyway i
was drinking a lot and obviously that
makes your metabolism go and i had to go
to the bathroom and i held it for so
long and then the one moment
the one moment that i went to go it just
it it was my time and then a woman ran
into the bathroom and i got god i don't
remember her name but she she grabbed me
by my wrist yanked me out and i was like
i've never been pulled so strongly in my
life and it was like the end of the
world it felt like but she pulled me and
i ran for my life it was beautiful and
i got to the stage i threw my
vape and i got on there and i did my
thing but yeah i know i was definitely
in the middle of a big piss
there's some miscellaneous woman who
saved the world tonight yeah she did and
i wish i knew her name she deserves
credit
but i can't give that to her because i
don't have it
congratulations you go and have fun
tonight thank you have fun god bless you
bless you congratulations
[Music]